[Music]
so with this workout we're gonna be
doing eight minutes of pure planking 30
seconds in between we're gonna be doing
two variations of planks and this is
going to work out everything from your
core your arms your shoulders your
hamstrings you're gonna feel it
everywhere trust me so the first
variation is going to be the standard
variation that's where you go flat on
your forearms making sure that your
elbow is directly aligned underneath
your shoulder the key here is making
sure that your head is perfectly in line
with your toes the second variation is a
side plank that's where you go back down
on one forearm having that elbow
directly underneath the shoulder blade
and kind of opening your body up to one
side bringing one hand up in the air
tightening your core so your body's
directly aligned with your toes head to
toe draw that imaginary line and really
engage all your muscles once again this
is going to work out your obliques that
you're gonna look at so let's get
started two minutes
standard plank blinking make sure that
we're breathing and really engaging your
abs as well
all right I'm already shaking guys
what's wrong with me
ten nine oh yeah yeah yeah sir is duty
to serve my name down all right we have
30 seconds and then we're gonna go right
into a side plank all right so get ready
no cheating
get those hips up common mistake hips
are sagging we want them up and we're up
I blink come on Tyree
minute and a half
let's get reaching those hips up a
little bit higher so let's get ready we
have ten seconds before the other side
plank
all right let's raise up one minute's
mental all mental guys ten seconds
[Music]
45 seconds 30 good this is what I call
the whale the beach as well a permanent
[Music]
three seconds we're almost there guys
motivate each other he's near Kelly
motivate diary oh this is no joke
just stand in one position
[Music]
Kairi you don't commit to this one I'm
gonna come over there ten all right that
was a great workout don't feel bad if
you fall down and take a extra break or
two and just get right back into it
that's all they're really matter comment
below what you want to do more of what
workouts you want to see what you likes
like the video share the video inspire
your friends go down we'll see you guys
next week